- And I'm a virgin.
- I'm a virgin.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- Why are you virgins?
- I grew up, like, Christian, so.
Well my mom was the
main one that was like,
"Make sure you wait."
And so, I don't know, it
kind of stuck with me.
- For me, I grew up religious
like you, but I'm 20 now,
so even for the past three
years, I'm not gonna lie,
it's not the religious aspect anymore,
I'm just bad with women.
- Keep it real. I'm Muslim.
For me it's like, why
not just wait and do it
through the Sharia?
Do it through the Din because you know,
but it's not worth going
to hellfire for me.
- So for me it's kind of a lot of reasons.
One, I was a super late bloomer.
I only felt sexual
attraction for the first time
like four years ago.
Looking like I do, women
usually aren't like bursting
to get down on this.
So, I haven't had anything
sort of just like fall
into my lap.
Yeah, it's not a priority right now.
- Does anyone know about
sexual transmutation?
- No.
- Essentially the desire
you have to have sex is
a very strong desire,
especially if you're a man.
Put it into the work, put it into the gym,
watch what will happen,
you will hit every goal.
So that's kind of my reason. Yeah.
- Nice.
- I want to do it because I
generally like want something
from you and with you, not
for just a simple like (beep).
- So it has to do with
Christianity as well.
It talks about in Romans, offer our bodies
as a living sacrifice, which
is a good and reasonable,
I'm underlining, reasonable service.
It's a gift that I want
to give to my future wife.
- How old is everyone here by the way?
- 22.
- 20.
- 23.
- 26.
- I'm 32.
- [Alexz] 32, dude respect
to you man, for waiting
- Three, two? And you ain't never...
- [Interviewer] Wait, let's
talk about that though,
because if you are not married by 32,
you will still be a virgin, correct?
- Yeah, but my God and he
ain't 'finna do me like that.
My God loves me.
It ain't no way you 32 and a virgin.
(people laughing)
(people chatting)
(bell rings)
- It seemed like he wanted
to present the extreme
of his religion.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(buzzer chimes)
- Shit, uh.
(people laughing)
- [Interviewer] Tell us how you felt.
- Oh, it was black. No, I'm kidding.
- I'm gonna ask you, like
you're 32, how does that go?
- How does it go?
It goes rough. I mean, my body is ready.
I want that. I want to be
married, but I put more value
on my walk with the
Lord and my future wife.
- Have you been in those
opportunities where like maybe...
- I could have had many opportunities,
but I keep myself away
from those types of things.
- Has everybody dated before
or have you guys had significant others?
I've only had one girlfriend, so...
- Yeah, me too, I've
only had one girlfriend.
- I've had two.
- I've had a handful.
(person laughing)
- I've never really had
an official boyfriend...
- [Alexz] Okay.
- But like I had seen
like two people, yes.
- So I'll go out like
on dates and whatnot,
but nothing really official.
- [Alexz] And have you
guys guys kissed or...
(person mumbling)
- Kissed, yes, nothing beyond.
- Got you.
- One of my long relationships
was entirely long distance.
She was in Portugal the whole time.
- [Alexz] Oh wow.
So like my lips don't really stretch
across the ocean very well.
(people laughing)
- Have you guys ever fell in love before?
- For sure.
- [Alexz] Okay.
- Really? Even though you
never dated anybody or...
- Yeah, for sure.
I'm a very passionate person.
When I was younger,
obviously you have like
those high school crushes and whatnot.
I don't wanna flex or
anything, but my car outside,
I bought it by myself, it's like $120K.
I opened my own company, and that's all
because I've stayed
focused and not let myself
become a part of, you know like
what's going on in society.
- I have a question for you
in the last five seconds.
I feel like a lot of people
accomplish a lot of things
(bell rings)
while still having sex
and you just make time
for it or you can just like
fap and forget about it, like.
- Yeah, but when they do
engage in that type of stuff,
they go through a heartbreak.
They could be successful
but they have to had
like this battle before all that happened.
- He kept talking about like
his mindset and grind-set,
and it reminded me of
like American Psycho,
and that guy (beep).
(upbeat instrumental music)
(buzzer chimes)
- Dang, that's crazy.
I thought I'd be eliminated right away.
But I've had naked
woman climb on top of me
and I still say no and then the next day,
I go submit three loans
and make like $10,000.
- [Interviewer] Interesting. Cool...
If you think the mole is still in the box
and you wish to continue playing the game
please raise your hand.
Wow.
- Oh interesting.
I didn't think y'all were
gonna raise your hands.
I have a bit of a accusation and I...
So Alexz, I think that you made a mistake,
and you are here rather
to promote that virginity
till marriage would've
been the better option.
- Yeah, I've definitely been
in the situations where me
and my girlfriend were making out
and there are definitely worse scenarios
that we could have gone farther than that.
This is gonna sound bad,
but I'm just too scared
of my mom to be like, "Hey, I had sex."
- But you only didn't have
sex because of your mom.
- When I turned 16, 17,
that was when I really
started diving into the Bible
and reading more into it
and kind of creating it
for my own, and so...
- What denomination is your church?
- I'll be honest with you,
I don't know which denomination it is,
but...
- Okay.
- [Alexz] We're Christian, so..
- [Alexz] I'll say that.
- Okay. Suspicious.
- He didn't know what
his denomination was,
like I feel like every
religious person knows what
their denomination is.
He definitely cares about his
religion way more than I do
and I know that my denomination
like the back of my hand.
I don't tell anyone that I'm a virgin,
it's definitely something
I really keep under wraps
'cause I feel very like
embarrassed and ashamed of it.
Like I've failed somehow.
Once when I was in college,
I was in this creative writing class
and the teacher, dramatic pause,
"Your next assignment is
to tell the true story
of your first kiss."
And I was like, "Oh god."
(people laughing)
And then she followed with,
"I know you've all had it."
And I was like, "Oh double God."
(person laughing)
- I do, yes, admit that I
feel pressured to have sex
because everyone else is
talking about their guy,
their girl.
And I'm like, okay, I'm
just like, what the f.
You know? Like.
(person laughing)
- I've been in band my whole
life starting in middle school
and I'm still in my college marching band.
It's actually kind of
uncommon when you say,
"Oh yeah I'm not a virgin."
They'll be like, they'll
kind of look at you like...
(people laughing)
"You played clarinet and you've had sex?"
- Growing up I played
football my whole life,
and so that was a very big deal,
especially at the high school I went to.
I would say definitely at
that time I felt the pressure
of just society saying like,
"Dude, you don't have sex?
Just go for it. It's easy."
I would rather wait, that's
me, in my opinion, so.
(bell rings)
(upbeat hip hop music)
- I just felt like what
Aaron said was really smart,
and it felt like a big
CSI moment so I was like,
"Oh, he definitely got him. That's it."
(upbeat hip hop music)
(buzzer chimes)
- Bummer. I wish I had like a virgin card
I could show you guys or something.
(person laughs)
- [Interviewer] If you
think the mole is still
in the box, and you wish to
continue playing the game
please raise your hand.
- I'm just super curious why
you two I guess didn't want
to continue?
- Because I think it was Alexz.
I think we are virgins.
- Yeah, I thought that what you said
during the last round was super smart.
It felt like a big CSI
moment so I was like,
"Oh, if you're wrong then like,
I don't trust anything anymore."
I think you definitely have the vibe
of like a band kid who hasn't done it yet.
Which I can say, cause
I used to be a band kid.
- What'd you play?
- I played trombone.
- Oh cool.
- Yeah.
- Nice.
- Yeah, but so you guys
think there's still...
(people exclaiming)
- Well here's the thing,
Aaron, I think it's you.
- And ask me why.
- And respectfully, I think it's
because you're imposing what you are
onto what Alexz was and
that's maybe what you did.
And I'm thinking that
you're, what's it called?
- [Aaron] Mmm, it's not.
- One more thing is just that because of,
you know, your age and everything...
- Yes.
- And I don't think age is, should matter.
- That's okay.
- It's hard to believe. Yes.
- Do you, I guess like what
was your longest relationship?
- About a year. A little over a year.
- [Irving] And then was
there times when she wanted
to like escalate it?
Because I know you're, you know...
- I've only dated Christian women.
- Right?
- And so they've also wanted
to maintain a certain level
of purity.
- [Irving] Okay. I see.
(clock ticking)
- Cool. Ominous.
(bell dings)
- It just seemed like
he wasn't as confident
as he was in the previous rounds.
So I was like, "Okay, you gotta go."
(buzzer chimes)
- Uh huh.
- [Interviewer] If you think
the mole's still in the box
and you wish to continue
playing, please raise your hand.
If the lights turn green
that means you have voted
the mole out and you win.
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
Three, two, one.
- What?
- It's you, huh?
- No...
- [Irving] It's you.
- You weren't surprised.
- No, it's you. No.
- [Carter] You weren't surprised.
You looked right at us.
You weren't surprised.
- [Interviewer] On the count of three,
can the mole please step out?
One, two, three.
- What up y'all?
(people laughing)
- He good. Like, oh, I wanted to say him,
but then the way he was
talking I'm like, nah.
But turns out he get hella meow.
- Well played.
- [Alexz] I like it.
- That was well played.
(person laughing)
'Cause I believed
everything that you said.
Most of what I said was true.
Those personal stories, they
were from before I, you know,
did the hunky-donk.
- I see.
(person laughing)
- I trusted him. I was like,
"Oh, he plays trombone.
I played clarinet. We're good."
- Wait, so when did you have sex then?
- Like eight times with,
or not eight times,
with eight different people.
(people laughing)
- Meow, meow.
(people mumbling)
He get meow.
- The big thing, the most important thing
that I'll probably say today,
and that's to all of
the young men out there
who don't look conventionally attractive
and feel like they will never find love
or sex because of it, no
matter what you look like,
there are plenty of
people who are into that.
It's just up to you to find
them, treat them with respect,
have good hygiene, you'll be just fine.
(case clicks)
Oh my God.
- [Interviewer] Celebrate
with your cash winning.
(person laughing)
( money clattering)
(person cheering)
Jesus. It's so slippery.
I didn't expect that.
(person laughing)
Wow.
(upbeat dance music)